[Music]
oh okay hey we're gonna play okay
playing varakovian um for the best
viewing experience it's probably
would be nice for people to watch both
like both commentary
uh good luck um okay
oh what's up playing against var let's
let's play a qgd
um so var var is among the top 200
players in the world
has played many u.s championships
he might hold a record for like the most
back-to-back
u.s championships
okay i played far before in like some of
the st louis chess club
over the board blitz events
i usually play bishop e7 i'm going to
try this new
sort of line the bishop d6 and then
eventually h6
yeah we'll see how up-to-date he is in
uh
like modern theory
ah so knight of three and knight three
is kind of uh
a more positional line i'm supposed to
play bishop here
and right here and then kind of just
chill
and some ideas of like trying to slow
down white's minority attack
yeah he's still trying to get it with uh
with pawn b4
i'm thinking queen b8 is a slightly
unusual idea
but just to create the battery and also
to preserve the c8 square for the rook
and yeah now here i could consider
playing b5
do i go for b5 immediately if i play b5
i have to be ready for takes
oh but then i could take here with the
bishop
let's do this oh but maybe a4
it's tricky if a4 i take and probably
take
i'll play b5
so b5 it's more of a preventive move i'm
trying to
prevent white from playing b5 himself
now let's take it's also controlling c
for which could be very nice for the
knight
and the drawback of the structure is
this pawn
is backwards on a half open file
but the benefit is the pawns are smiling
this pawn's a bit weak too
it's isolated and constantly attacked
95 makes sense 95 makes a lot of sense
because this pawn is
lacking any sort of support
let's play this move
the defending so that was maybe one
reason to put the queen here is to
have this move eventually
and pieces are still kind of just
chilling
staying within my own territory now this
move threatening knight a3
93 is sometimes easily overlooked but
and he's going to see it
the sideways alekhine's gone yeah
usually it's more powerful to have the
pieces aligned on the same file rather
than the same rank
i just went up hauling here he saw this
but did you see this
let's take a free pawn
oh maybe he's gonna comp it shouldn't be
that bad i have this move
i could also maybe take no i can't i
can't take as my bishop pin
play this move first
and defends the pawn attempts to
restrict the knight
um i'll admit this is a little bit
uncomfortable
but it's not too bad i think i can take
and play queen d6
and this pawn's weak but this one's also
a target okay four ideas
oh but he could get a gun
yeah for those unfamiliar with the
alkyne's gun is when your three
major pieces are lined up on the same
file
it can be very deadly but he goes for
the
the defensive gun kind of
i have to watch my time
i mean i'm thinking just rook
yeah okay four so now
i have two attackers so this uh like the
queen and rook are both tied down to the
pawn
i'm also preparing the double up maybe
eventually rook a1
or rook a3
also realizing this knight is not the
happiest
it's just kind of sitting around doing
nothing would much rather be on c4
bishop f5 is a bit tricky
bishop five is actually very wise
so if i take
the taking just gives white too much
initiative
i'm thinking just g6
and then recapture with knight ah
if i if i take with knight there's this
move
his tactics i have to take with queen
and c-pawn's probably going to be a
goner
but it's interesting because if he
really tries to win c6
i could maybe win b4
i'm also realizing there's there's
forking potential i should have
considered 94
to go into d2
forgot about that move does that work
i kind of have to take it and then pray
take and pray um
don't hurt me i'll be this move
i don't know if he's trying to draw or
trying to beat me
probably trying to be me
i'm up wait what's the material
bishop for two pawns wow it's a rain wow
it's a gotham rain what's up gotham
chess
thanks for raining appreciate that shout
out to gotham
if you're just joining it's kind of
intense time scramble situation i'm
playing gm var kobian
uh this is three plus two and he just
sacked a piece trying to
destroy my king i'm kind of scared
let's avoid the draw for content
but also because it might i might just
be better here
like the knights restricted the queens
will only attack ooh this is a good move
and the knight wants to join the party i
can play this move
and then hide the king
i don't have to hide the wife because i
don't have a wife
i hide the king in this way
or i could just take i should probably
take
it's just simpler to play with five
seconds left and then take here
and we're gonna we're gonna have a race
scenario where white has
pawns and i have pawns material is
actually balanced
weirdly enough put the queen in the
center and start running the b
pawn oh the rook wants to come in
let's prevent it controlling these
squares not the square
also supporting the pawn with this move
ah don't flag me
oh good move oh this is unpleasant
i'm defending
ah don't hurt me
i have to play this really sad move
at least the bishop attacks
draw oh no
wait i can take i think he's just
blundering it
back
is this position
yeah my pawn
i'm finding a fork
this is so stressful like this move
attacking
kind of not really
what's going on here wanna put the
bishop
in the center or just run no i blundered
ah
please let me promote no
ah i resign well played what a game
what a game i don't know what happened
that game that was a crazy game
alright guys so we'll take a look at the
first game
and and then uh there were some some
interesting openings eric played
so yeah um what i'm doing is i'm
bringing the games into a leachate study
okay and i'll go ahead and invite you to
uh the study too perfect yeah we can
look at this one
sure so so i played this uh it's kind of
a
new emerging line against the queen's
gambit i was curious if you've like
looked at this at all from either side
yeah no i uh yeah this is interesting
this bishop d6 i've i
have a little bit of experience playing
against playing playing against it a
little bit
but uh the key is not to put a knight on
e2 because in this lines if you put a
knight only two then
you always have to watch out for the
bishop h2 sacrifice
when you castle like for example you
play an ipd7
and then it's if i castle i would
actually play a5
a5 to support knight a6 but it's the
same idea yeah exactly with castling
yeah and then you have this ideas i've
had this a few times in
uh sure in online games yeah yeah no
absolutely yeah i've
i i've played against this few times it
was very unpleasant so
that's why i put the knight on it but i
think this game we played really well
and i thought
you you outplayed man i missed something
there
um not exactly sure where where i went
wrong
but yeah i mean this this idea with
queen b8 and eventually b5 is it's like
the one idea i know in the structure
yeah
and it kind of worked out well i'm
thinking maybe my b4 was a bit too early
so a3 and also by the way there was a
moment here after
queen b8 i thought you had an idea
uh take take is it synced up for you
like you can move pieces too right
yeah oh sorry sorry okay can you see it
yes okay perfect
so i i was wondering if you looked at
this move here either take
take and bishop g4 idea oh
i i did not consider bishop g4 what's
the point
the point is just to take on f3 and take
on h2 hmm and
if i play h3 now you take on f3 and then
g5
ah oh wow oh that's actually really nice
yeah it's really good i think for you i
think i have to play bishop g3 but then
i think
my position it's not that bad
but i don't know this this position uh
uh i'm not sure yeah maybe i would leave
the tension
maybe still b5 and then knight b6 knight
c4
because you know if you get the knight
on c4 with this with this uh double
structure here i think
uh i don't think i can never the problem
with this structure eric the main
problem is i can never play e4
which is usually your main plan when i
have phones like this yeah if i play
e4 then you're going to put a knight on
f4 then it's going to be really bad
so that's the main problem with this
structure here and
since position is already open on a
queen side then it's going to be hard
for me to play king h1 rook g1 i think
that's just going to be too long
so i think this is this is another idea
that you could have done okay
yeah that's good to know yeah like i've
i don't have too much experience
playing this line i only started playing
it like a few months ago
and uh i only checked knight f3 even
more recently
with this queen b8 idea so it's nice to
know this resource
like combining like exploiting the
knight the pawn and the bishop
like all kind of simultaneously yeah
absolutely yeah
so b4 and i think uh i decided to play
bishop g3 now but i think
somehow it didn't quite work out for me
maybe i should have trade
maybe i should have trade on d6
maybe i should have traded on d6 i'm
thinking now bishop d6
take and try to remaneuver the knight on
c5 very quickly but
knight c4 is coming and the problem is
it's very hard for me to contest for the
a file because the b4 pawn is weak
like i can never do this because i will
drop this pawn that's true
right yeah it's a drawback for whites
yeah if i manage to get a knight on c5
then i'm slightly better here but but
every time i try to do it like i'm
dropping this one
and normally you do this a little bit
different but i think your pieces are
actually perfectly placed here
so i think it's it's it's probably about
equal here but maybe a little bit easier
to play for black actually
yeah yeah i was i was feeling
comfortable until like this time
scramble situation
yeah yeah okay let's go forward yeah
so i honestly didn't see uh this bishop
g
i i didn't even consider bishop g6 for
you oh when you play g6 yeah
um right here yeah if you want to like
go forward to this moment
yeah yeah yeah um yeah i i actually
if i take on d7 then it's uh
which i was expecting because i can't
take back with knight because you take
on b5
yeah so you're gonna take with the queen
i guess
but this is but this is also not bad you
know because i can now take on c6
and threatening knight b5 i think
even this is probably going to be okay
for me because
now if rook rook to here i can just
take on b5 yeah i know i thought i was
going to end up like losing
one of the pawns in some way or another
it's probably going to be equal at the
sacrifice i'm not sure if it's if it's
that good objectively speaking if it
wasn't a bliss game i would have
not done it but uh yeah
we repeated it but of course you're
better here after kingston here
i didn't see anything i can do actually
so that's the only thing i just that's
why i played knight f3 because
i think objectively this is just winning
for you well i said
i said during during the game that like
your queen can't attack alone and then
you play knight f3 and then like kind of
i guess panicked yeah i think you played
correctly you played the best move
i just don't know why you took because
if you just go here
i just don't see a threat you know yeah
i i just panicked and i think
we can see
[Music]
okay i had about 12 seconds left so i i
just assumed like taking and taking is
easier to play than letting your knight
survive
but sure sure if i spend like a few more
seconds realizing you don't have a
follow-up yeah
i i don't have any follow in fact i
don't know what to do after queen e5
next
ah yeah yeah you just centralize your
right i mean you're threatening to take
on before
so i was thinking i was thinking to play
this to this protectors
but then after you go here now i have to
do something with this night
you have rk1 ideas coming up
and yeah like i i was i was still
pleased with this position but
yeah i think i think you're still you're
still probably winning after rook g5
uh-huh but uh at least now i have i have
this hope i played this because i was
constantly worried about lifting the
rook and then getting mated with queenie
one and knight g4
so and then i thought maybe i can make a
break
i think uh
maybe even queen d2 is very good for you
here queen d2
and just yeah i wasn't sure like
of course i want to attack on the king
side but i also wanted to just push my
pawns
there's a few different ideas we should
be sick maybe yeah i think i think
you're just
probably winning just pushing the b palm
but practically like anything can happen
in the time scramble yeah yeah
yeah no it was it was it was a scramble
okay yeah